>> ♪ ♪
>> Tucker: THIS IS THE
CONSERVATIVE COMEDIAN WHO MAKES
VIDEOS ON youTUBE AND HAS 4
MILLION SUBSCRIBERS.
HIS STUFF IS NOT FOR EVERYONE
BUT SO?
IF YOU DON'T LIKE HIS VIDEOS
WATCH SOMETHING ELSE.
IT'S A FREE COUNTRY.
A WRITER AT FOX.COM DEMANDED
THAT youTUBE BAND CROWDER FOR
INSULTING HIM.
MANY IN THE WASHINGTON PRESS
CORPS AGREE.
THE PERSON LEVELLED RACIST
ATTACKS ON LINE AND WHINES ABOUT
BEING A VICTIM HIMSELF.
A FASCIST POSING AS A VICTIM.
NO ADULT WILL TAKE HIM SERIOUSLY
BUT youTUBE IS OBEYING HIS
COMMAND.
youTUBE IS KILLING CROWDER'S
BUSINESS.
THEY ADMITTED HE BROKE NO RULES.
VOCE
VOXE
VOX TOLD youTUBE TO TAKE HIM
AURORA.
-- OFF.
WHY IS THIS ALLOWED TO CONTINUE?
youTUBE AND THE NEW PUBLIC
SQUARE.
TECH COMPANIES HAVE SPECIAL
IMMUNITY FROM BEING SUED FOR
FRAUD.
THE PURPOSE IS TO ALLOW TRUE I
HAVE DIVERSITY OF POLITICAL
DISCOURSE.
THE EFFECT IS IMMUNITY.
THAT'S WORTH TENS OF BILLION
DOLLARS.
IT'S ONE OF THE REASONS THE
OWNERS OF TWITTER AND FACEBOOK
AND GOOGLE ARE SO RICH.
YOU GUARANTEED THAT TO THEM
THROUGH REPRESENTATIVES IN THE
CONGRESS.
IN RETURN THESE TECH COMPANIES
VIOLATE THE TERMS OF THE DEAL
EVERY MINUTE OF EVERY DAY.
THEY ARE NOT OPEN FORUMS.
THEY ARE EXERCISES IN CONTROL
AND CENSORSHIP.
THE QUESTION IS:
HOW LONG WILL THE REST OF US
STAND FOR THIS.
THANKS FOR COMING ON.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO BE A FAN OF
CROWDER OR ANYONE TO SEE THIS AS
A THREAT TO ONE PERSON'S SPEECH
IS A THREAT TO ALL OF OUR
SPEECH.
IS IT NOT?
>> YES.
I FIND CROWDER TO BE A CRETE
I FIND CROWDER TO BE A CRETAN.
I THINK HE IS A BULLY AND BIGOT.
HE DID NOT JUST CRITICIZE
CARLOS, HE MOCKED HIM FOR BEING
GAY AND LATINA AND SENT A LOT OF
HARASSMENT HIS WAY.
THAT'S THE POINT.
CENSORSHIP ADVOCATES WANT OUR
BRAINS TO JUST GO TO THE FIRST
LEVEL OF:
DO WE HATE THEIR PERSON AND ARE
WE GLAD THEY ARE BEING CENSORED?
WITHOUT THINKING ABOUT THE
CONSEQUENCES.
IT RESONATES WITH ME.
I AM A GAY MAN IN BRAZIL.
MY HUSBAND IS A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS ON THE OPPOSITIONAL
PARTY.
WE HAVE BEEN MOCKED BY NOT
youTUBE BUT BY THE PRESIDENT OF
THE COUNTRY HIMSELF ON TWITTER
AND HIS FAMILY MEMBERS WHO ARE
ELECTED MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
IT WOULD NEVER OCCUR TO ME TO
RUN TO SOCIAL MEDIA COMPANIES TO
BEG FOR CENSORSHIP?
IN PART IT COMES WITH THE
TERRITORIES OF BEING A PUBLIC
FIGURE.
I DON'T WANT TO LIVE IN A WORLD
WHERE OUR DISCOURSE IS POLICED
AND DETERMINED BY OVERLORDS WHO
RUN SILICONE VALLEY COMPANIES
AND WILL ALWAYS CATER TO THE
MOST POWERFUL FACTION.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
youTUBE CAVED IN DEFENSE OF THE
POWERFUL ONE WHO WORKS FOR A
MAJOR MEDIA COMPANY.
THAT'S WHAT THEY WILL ALWAYS DO.
DEFEND THE MOB AND THE POWERFUL
AT THE EXPENSE OF THOSE WHO ARE
MARGINALIZED.
>> Tucker: THAT'S SUCH A GOOD
POINT!
YOU DON'T HAVE IMMUNITY THAT
youTUBE ENJOYS WHICH IS GRANTED
BY CONGRESS.
YOU FOUNDED A BIG AND WELL KNOWN
SITE.
IF YOU LIBEL SOMEONE YOU CAN BE
SUED.
WHY DO THEY RETAIN IMMUNITY?
>> THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
ORIGINALLY youTUBE, GOOGLE,
TWITTER AND FACEBOOK WERE
SUPPOSED TO BE LIKE AT&T.
NEUTRAL PUBLIC PLATFORMS.
IF CROWDER WANTS TO CALL SOMEONE
USING AT&T AN ANTI-VOX RALLY
NOBODY EXPECTS HIM TO GET AT&T
TO STOP HIM.
IN REALITY, THIS POWER TO CENSOR
WAS NOT ONE THEY WANTED.
IT WAS ONE THAT WAS HOISTED HELP
THEM LARGELY BY JOURNALISTS WHO
DEMANDED THEY REMOVED VOICES
FROM THE INTERNET.
IMAGINE GOING TO JOURNALISM AND
BEGGING CORPORATIONS TO SILENCE
PEOPLE.
THAT'S WHY THEY ENDED UP THIS IN
POSITION.
>> Tucker: THAT'S SO NICELY PUT.
FEDERAL PROSECUTORS REVEALED
CHARGES AGAINST THE WIKI LEAK
FOUNDER.
HAVE YOU BEEN CLOSE TO THIS
STORY FROM DAY 1.
YOUR POINT IS THIS COULD
CRIMINALIZE ORDINARY JOURNALISM.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> A LOT OF YOUR VIEWERS
PROBABLY REMEMBER UNDER THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION A LOT OF
JOURNALISTS WERE CALLED
CRIMINALS FOR WORKING WITH
SOURCES INCLUDING ROSEN WHO
WORKED WITH A SOURCE WHO LEAKED
CLASSIFIED MATERIAL.
THEY NEVER CRIMINALIZED THE
PEOPLE WHO PUBLISHED THAT
MATERIAL.
THE TRUMP JUSTICE DEPARTMENT
SAID THAT WIKI LEAKS IS CRIMINAL
NOT BECAUSE THEY STOLE THE
INFORMATION BUT BECAUSE THEY
PUBLISHED.
WE HAVE SEEN ON THE LEFT AND THE
RIGHT THE CIA AND THE FBI ARE
AGENCIES WILL THAT ABUSE THEIR
POWER UNLESS THEY HAVE GREAT
TRANSPARENCY SHINED ON THEM.
THEY WANT TO PUNISH ASSANGE.
IF YOU PUBLIC SECRET INFORMATION
YOU CAN BE TURNED INTO A
CRIMINAL.
THAT'S WHY IT'S SO DANGEROUS TO
PRESS FREEDOM.
>> Tucker: THAT'S THE KEY POINT.
THEY WHIP THE MOB INTO THE